ja das sind bilder einer
überwachungskamera so aufgenommen in
thüringen ein mann geht an die
eingangstür holt dann aus seinem
rucksack etwas das wie ein sehr großes
dickes kabel aussieht und hält es an die
haustüre fragt natürlich was macht der
da im hintergrund sehen wir dass die
scheinwerfer vom auto am straßenrand
angehen das muss wohl das auto des
hausbesitzers seien jetzt geht der
vermummte
leiche weg
halter das kabel wo jetzt schon
drin und dann geht er weg und auch das
wurde fett weg ja geklaut von zwei
unbekannten ohne schlüssel ohne dass das
auto aufgebrochen werden muss das ist
scheinbar eine ganz neue und besonders
dreiste masche von autodieben und was
bei diesem auto klaut technisch passiert
und wie sie sich als autobesitzer vor
dieser dreisten masche schützen können
das klären wir jetzt und als kleiner
vorgeschmack
diese dose hier wenn wir sie sehen eine
herrlich schlagen jetzt nur sagen ich
glaube du gehst mal rüber
gekommen unser sicherheitsexperte
hagemann herzlich willkommen bei uns wir
haben es gerade schon angesprochen eine
dose die haben sie mitgebracht flüchtig
was ist das für eine dose und in welchem
verhältnis steht die zu den bildern die
wir gerade gesehen haben also diese dose
schützt vor solchen angriffen aber das
was wir da gerade gesehen haben in dem
video ist eine masche die ist schon über
15 jahre alt hat auch die autohersteller
tun nichts machen wirklich gar nichts
und versuchen also wirklich gehört auch
hin zu halten und den leuten zu sagen es
ist alles sicher und ihre systeme sind
sicherung bleiben sicher und sie ändern
nichts also sind so fadenscheinige
ausreden jeder der straße
kinderleicht aus was er da gesehen haben
wir wollen das hier noch mal kurz
angucken mit ihnen zusammen
genau hier sehen wir es noch mal das
bild der herkommt ist es mitten in der
nacht und packt dann dieses dicke kabel
aus es sieht aus wie ein stromkabel es
ist aber nicht das ist ein magnetfeld
antenne und wenn er diese hält und
versucht er damit
signal dass schüssel zu bekommen möchte
den schlüsseln sagen antwortete mir um
das fahrzeug zu öffnen und deswegen hält
er diese antenne dorthin so einer
antenne nicht in dieser größe aber
sondern antenne ist im auto eingebaut
das heißt wenn ich als autor angehe ist
hier ich klar also sagt ja schüsse
sofort jawohl das ist das richtige ins
richtige auto zu auto sagt ist der
richtige schlüssel und somit eröffnet
das fahrzeug und dieses ganze ding was
sie hier sehen ist tatsächlich eine
einzige magnetfeld antenne die versucht
hier durch die tür genau wie versucht
hier durch die tür das signal des
schlüssels abzufangen dem schiff
sozusagen öffnen wir das auto und dann
öffnet der schüssel das auto und nicht
diese reichweiten völlig egal wie ich
wieder mein okay schauen wir uns das
noch mal hier auf diesem
weiteren bild an ihre halter das nochmal
hohe antenne und
was passiert dann genau also er muss
dann gar nicht mehr zum auto gehen
sondern das passiert dann alles
automaten er also dieser angriff
funktioniert halt nur mit zwei versuchen
also eine sitzt im auto oder steht am
auto erhält die antenne dran dann sagt
der schüssel okay ich bin oder denkt der
schüssel ich bin nah am fahrzeug dann
kann man die tür öffnen der setzt sich
rein dass staaten ist ein bisschen
schwieriger deswegen hantierte der auch
soeben mit dieser sowie diese antenne um
dann eben das signal zu bekommen start
den wir das fahrzeug und dann macht er
schluss belassen
ich möchte jetzt keine hinweise geben
wie man auto klauen kann aber wo bekommt
man das ja da muss das ist das ein
eigenbau das sieht man ja auch es ist im
eigenbau die dinger sind auch im
schwarzmarkt erhältlich das sind die
ganz schön teuer aber ich hab da öfter
auch schon gehört dass diebe dann fragen
ich habe
viel geld du hast ein gerät gibt mir das
bitte und mit zwei autos geklauten autos
er das gerät hat schon wieder drin es
ist tatsächlich so dass betrüger in
osteuropa diese geräte dann auch kaufen
oder diebe und da da kann man wirklich
gegen diese art methode im moment immer
noch nichts machen weil die hersteller
einfach nichts tun und das ist das was
mich so maßlos ärgert dass ich seit 15
jahren immer wieder den hersteller
versuchen zu erklären das system
unsicher ist so zeige ihnen das auch der
verweigern das eigentlich und sagen
unsere autos sind sicher auf der anderen
seite sagen sie dann noch
sehen weil es so unglaublich ist und ich
glaube ich habe persönlich solche bilder
noch nie gesehen das ist das ist
einmalig oder haben sie schon mal so ein
autoklau court on tape gesehen natürlich
selbstverständlich ich habe den
herstellern ist auch demonstriert sagt
steen gezeigt mit so einem gerät und
gezeigt wie einfach es ist ihre autos
sicher zu machen und aber auch gezeigt
wie einfache sie ihre autos zu stehlen
ich habe meine frage da habe ich mal von
hinaus darin rufen
könnte man sich den schützen indem man
den schlüssel also den autoschlüssel der
man normalerweise wenn man reinkommt an
der tür ab liegt eben nicht an der tür
ab liegt sondern weiter irgendwo im
wohnzimmer schlafen wenn man in einem
anderen raum also nicht direkt an
natürlich nie fast nicht weil es kommt
immer darauf an wenn in der nähe auch
ein fenster ist es die signal dieses
magnetfeld signal wird sogar durch wände
hindurch gestrahlt zwar ist die
reichweite ein bisschen kürzer aber wir
haben ja versuche gemacht küchenfenster
autoschlüssel hing im wohnhaus also
nicht im einfamilienhaus oder
mehrfamilienhaus da gibt's ja auch ein
treppenhaus hing an der tür wir haben
durch das küchenfenster das signal
abfangen können und das auto geöffnet
und gestartet am sichersten sind
wirklich solche dosen hier dieses risiko
case damit ist es sicherheits
box wo man eben den schlüssel rein
stecken kann damit dieses abgeschirmt
mit metall zu hause intensiv pflegen
oder im kühlschrank tut es natürlich
auch also da sind diese schlüssel sicher
ansonsten mit seinem tisch liegen lassen
egal wo im haus ist es überall
irgendeine fenster in der nähe wo man
das signal an april den kühlschrank
die dose nehmen das klingt absurd es ist
so einfach ja und trotzdem haben es die
wenigsten autobesitzer zwar richtig die
meisten haben ebenso einen
davon kräftig drauf eine kleinere
boxerin
kleinere schlüssel und offenthal besser
doppelt hält besser und damit kann man
diese schüssel absolut absichern er hat
man es in der tasche es ist ein metall
drum rum und das stimmt eben die
magnetfelder ab die diese sechs antennen
erzeugen haben sie irgendeine info
darüber wo das auto abgeblieben ist
können sie informationen zu diesem fall
hier liefern nähe zu diesem fall kann
ich jetzt nicht sagen aber zu anderen
fällen die gehen meistens nach osteuropa
und meine die haben schon festgestellt
und autos zurückgeholt die minister
gefallen haben in osteuropa die wirklich
politiker ist noch nicht vorbei die
chance ist noch da das der besitzer sein
auto wieder sieht ja wenn er auch wenn
auch klein weil es war ja kein keine
große staatskarosse die also aber
gelesen zu haben dass dieses auto
trotzdem 80.000 euro wert hat und ja
also haben eine meistens werden diese
autos ausgeschlachtet und ersatzteile
dann ob die schwarz machen hofft hoffen
wir das beste in diesem fall für den
besitzer vielen dank herr gemeint gänge
schön
[Musik]